[Music]
as a veteran and as a realtor i saw
firsthand veteran homelessness and
wanted to solve that problem
we have a veterans village of 49 tiny
homes which allows us to provide
transitional housing for homeless
veterans
[Music]
how are you a lot of people think
homeless vets won't work they don't want
to be a part of society
and
none of those things are true about me
[Music]
good morning i feel a special bond with
everyone here hi little one welcome to
the
we're village trying to restart our
lives we have fallen down and we're
learning how to get up again thank you
so much
mr leo how's petey doing it's a
community it's people helping people
they make sure that their battle buddy
or shipmate is taken care of good luck
to you mr leo
as a realtor we're out in the community
every single day helping connect people
with services and each other when i
first came on board with bcp i was able
to connect the organization with the
right services and get up and running it
allowed me the opportunity to take my
military experience and my real estate
business experience and figure out how
to solve veteran homelessness with
housing
these are all my pictures that i've
saved over the years and brought with me
and this one
started it all
when i turned 18 i joined the military i
met a man i fell in love with we got
married and we left to start our new
life
my husband wasn't a good man he was very
abusive mentally and physically
and as soon as my children grew up i
filed for divorce and i ended up losing
my home
[Music]
when a veteran comes to our village our
goal is to transition all of these vets
out to independent living this blanket
was here when i moved in it was my
housewarming gift when i move out of
this home i'm moving into my home
a new start
[Music]
think of the lady who showed up here
when you first got here and the person
you are today and how different those
people are
you may think vcp
has helped you i'm not kidding when i
say that you have helped us you've
helped us learn
you've helped us grow you've helped us
figure out what works and what doesn't
work and thank you that's not me doing
it you're doing the hard work every day
i will also tell you this right when
they see these boxes going out you're
showing them what is next right
that's also very powerful you will be
successful
i'm nervous because this is the first
time i'm out on my own by myself
i'm also excited because i have a great
support system around me am i going to
surprise the neighborhood
helping veterans get off the streets
that's what gets me going every day oh i
can't wait to get my family together in
this room picture where all your stuff
is going to be uh kinda sorta kinda
sorta
all the magic is gonna go down right
here oh we cooking everything everything
vcp gave me a new future i'm not afraid
anymore i have confidence oh that's
perfect perfect look at that i feel like
i can go forward now good job
and i don't have to be ashamed of my
story
[Music]